Billy is in Fargo North Dakota
hi Billy how are you hi there Dave I'm
doing well how are you better than I
deserve what's up well sir I graduated
college and I got a new job and to
celebrate three years ago I went bought
a brand new pickup of course yeah and
now three years later I'm looking at
trying to expand my cattle business and
I'm sick and tired of paying that large
car payments and I'm actually six grand
upside down on this pickup and I don't
know if I'm in too deep and I need to
try and ride it out for the remainder of
the loan or do I need to cut my losses I
own 29 okay no you're not too deep you
need to sell it
okay what's your household income 48
yeah $30,000 truck payment it's insanity
[Music]
most people do this is why I'm laughing
Billy of it it's like a classic thing
come out of college and celebrate by
punishing myself yeah I have another 98
that I could drive and fix up good do it
so and I feel like I feel like I'm good
enough of a a grease monkey to be able
to take care of an all the vehicle well
and for a little while because all you
did get 6,000 paid off because you're
going to go borrow the 6000 that you're
upside down right how do you owe the
money - on the truck an intermediary an
intermediary what's that mean okay
that's great go sit down with the credit
union tell them you want to sell the
truck and sign a note for the difference
okay but do it in person sit down with
the credit union manager and go I make
40 I have a $30,000 truck payment this
is insanity
I have to get rid of this truck and I
need you guys to let me get rid of it
and I'll sign a note for the difference
and I'll pay off the note within just a
few months all right and you get rid of
6,000 upside down that way right yeah
and then when that's done then you
save up like crazy and move up out of
your 98 in with cash okay never again
have a car payment promise me I promise
you mr. Ramsey you have to learn your
lessons that way you don't have to learn
them twice okay you got it sir
be good Billy